This is 99% invisible. I'm Roman Mars. Hello, beautiful, homebound nerds. If I sound a little different, it's because I'm recording this at home. You might even hear some cars passing by. I'm not sick. Hopefully, neither are you, but many of us are staying home so that we don't inadvertently become vectors to a virus whose impact we don't fully understand. This is the right thing to do. We are all part of one big ecosystem, and if any part of us get sick, we all suffer. We are in this together. So my job in this world is to tell stories about all the thought that goes into the things
这里是99% Invisible。我是罗曼·马斯。你好，美丽的、足不出户的书呆子们。如果听起来有点不一样，那是因为我是 在家里录音的。你甚至可能会听到一些汽车驶过的声音。我没有生病。希望你们也没有，但我们中的许多人都在呆在家里，这样我们就不会无意中成为一种我们对其影响尚未完全了解的病毒的传播媒介。这是正确的事情。我们都是一个庞大生态系统的一部分，如果我们当中的任何一部分生病了，我们所有人都会痛苦。我们同舟共济。所以我在这个世界上的工作是讲述那些融入到事物中的所有深思熟虑的故事
most people don't think about. And since many of us are stuck at home, maybe alone, maybe lonely, I thought, we'd spend some time exploring this place we call home together. Just you and me. Sound good? If you answer back out loud, I won't think you're weird. I am starting in my bedroom. I'm sitting on a Casper mattress. This is not an ad.
大多数人不会去想。既然我们很多人都呆在家里，也许孤单，也许寂寞，我想，我们可以花点时间一起探索这个我们称之为家的地方。只有你和我。听起来不错吗？如果你大声回答我，我不会觉得你奇怪。我从我的卧室开始。我正坐在卡斯帕（Casper）床垫上。这不是广告。
We eat our own dog food in the podcast business, so I have a Casper mattress, but I digress. As I look around, I see I have five windows in this room. Now, if I were in England or France or Ireland or Scotland during the 18th and 19th centuries, I would probably not want this many windows. That's because back then, the more windows you had, the more tax you paid. This was all variable from place to place and over time, but the principle was that a window tax was a good stand-in for a progressive income tax. The bigger the house, the more windows, the higher the tax you paid. When the window tax was instituted in 1696 in England and Wales, a home was taxed at a regular
我们在播客行业里自己吃自己的狗粮，所以我有一个卡斯帕床垫，但我扯远了。当我环顾四周时，我看到这个房间里有五个窗户。现在，如果我在18和19世纪的英国、法国、爱尔兰或苏格兰，我可能不会想要这么多窗户。那是因 为在那时，你拥有的窗户越多，你交的税就越多。这些因地而异、随时间而变，但其原则是，窗户税可以很好地替代累进所得税。房子越大，窗户越多，你交的税就越高。1696年，英国和威尔士实行窗户税时，房屋按常规税率征税
flat rate and then taxed an extra amount for each window over a 10 windows that had. Like I said, the number of windows in the amount of tax varied a lot over time, but the tax was pretty easy to assess by an outside observer. It was certainly considered easier to assess than an income tax, and so it persisted for quite some time in some places into the 20th century. This had a funny side effect on architecture that you can still see today in some buildings in the UK and in Europe.
固定税率，然后超过10扇窗户的每扇窗户都要额外征税。就像我说的，窗户的数量和税收金额随时间变化很大，但这种税对于外部观察者来说很容易评估。它当然被认为比所得税更容易评估，因此在某些地方它持续了相当长的一段时间，一直到20世纪。这对建筑产生了一个有趣的副作用，你在英国和欧洲的一些建筑中今天仍然可以看到。
There are many instances of window spaces that are completely bricked up to avoid attacks from 100 years ago. Now, if you passed one in your neighborhood, it means some tax cheat lived there a long time ago, or an enterprising life hacker lived there, depending on your perspective. On a test of drawers next to my bed, it's an oscillating fan that I've had for about 35 years.
有很多窗户空间完全被砖砌堵死的例子，用来逃避100年前的税。现在，如果你路过你邻居家的一个，这意味着很久以前有一个逃税者住在那里，或者一个富有进取心的生活黑客住在那里，这取决于你的视角。在我床头的一个抽屉柜上，有一个我已经用了大约35年的摇头风扇。
It still works really well. It's a windom year. I've done a little googling and honestly I cannot tell you if this company still exists. The fan mostly points away from the bed. I just use it for white noise when I sleep. If I were in Korea running a fan in an enclosed bedroom might be discouraged by older generations. There is by some accounts still a widespread belief in Korea that fans cause death. No one seems to know how this myth started.
它仍然运作得非常好。这是一个Windom牌的。我刚刚用谷歌搜索了一下，老实说，我无法告诉你这家公司是否还存在。风扇大部分时间都背对着床。我睡觉时只是用它来制造白噪音。如果我在韩国，在封闭的卧室里开风扇可能会遭到老一辈的反对。根据一些说法，韩国仍然广泛存在一种迷信，认为风扇会致人死亡。似乎没有人知道这个神话是如何开始的。
Maybe fans are just an innocent bystander to too many he related deaths, but nonetheless, the fear persists. I remember when I was a kid growing up in the Southern US, I was told that if you slept with a fan blowing on you in the summer, you'd catch a summer cold, which is just as unfounded, but still nowhere does fan equal death like Korea. Well, I'm going to get up from the bed and let's go ahead and walk into the bathroom. Okay, all right, so there is the toilet. There's an extremely common misconception that the toilet was invented by a man named Thomas Crapper. Crapper was a sanitation engineer and entrepreneur in the UK in the late 19th century that held
也许风扇只是太多与热相关死亡事件的无辜旁观者，但尽管如此，这种恐惧依然存在。我记得当我还是个在美国南部长大的孩子时，有人告诉我，如果在夏天睡觉时开着风扇对着自己吹，你会得“夏季感冒”，这同样毫无根据，但没有任何地方的风扇能像韩国那样等同于死亡。好吧，我要从床上起来，我们去卫生间看看。好吧，好吧，所以这里是马桶。有一个极其普遍的误解，认为马桶是由一个叫托马斯·克拉珀（Thomas Crapper）的人发明的。克拉珀是19世纪后期英国的一名卫生工程师和企业家，他拥有
a few patents and he's credited with improving indoor plumbing for toilets. He was a good businessman and by all accounts he installed and sold a lot of plumbing supplies with the name Crapper and company on them. No one is quite sure why he gets so much credit for the flushing toilet, but I think it's because his name was Crapper. Crap as a term for bodily excrement was already in use for decades before he made toilet parts, so sometimes destiny just smiles upon you. While we're here in the bathroom, let's wash our hands. That's good COVID-19 protocol. Soap is one
几项专利，他因改进了室内厕所的管道系统而受到赞誉。他是个好商人，据各方反映，他安装和销售了大量印有“克拉珀父子公司”（Crapper and Company）字样的管道用品。没有人十分确定为什么他能获得如此多关于抽水马桶的赞誉，但我认为这是因为他的名字叫克拉珀（Crapper）。在你造出马桶零件之前的几十年里，“便便”（crap）一词作为身体排泄物的代名词就已经在使用，所以有时候命运就是会向你微笑。当我们在卫生间里时，让我们洗洗手。这是很好的COVID-19防疫规程。肥皂是
of those inventions that is so monumental. It's hard to even fathom. It's so ancient. No one knows who first discovered it. There was a very good explainer on soap recently in New York Times by Ferris Jaber. Soap molecules look like little sperm with a head that loves water and a tail that hates water. So when you put soap and water on your hands, these little soap tails find things that aren't water and they dig their tails in to try to get away. This breaks up bacteria and virus cell membranes and surrounds any debris with soap molecules and makes them easy to rinse away when more water and friction are applied. For the sake of your own health and for everyone else's, wash your hands regularly for
那些如此具有划时代意义的发明之一。简直难以想象。它是如此古老。没有人知道是谁最先发现它的。最近《纽约时报》的费里斯·贾伯（Ferris Jabr）对肥皂进行了一次非常好的解释。肥皂分子看起来像小小的精子，有一个喜欢水的头部和一个讨厌水的尾巴。因此，当你把肥皂和水弄到手上时，这些小肥皂尾巴会寻找不是水的东西，并把它们的尾巴插进去以设法逃离。这会破坏细菌和病毒的细胞膜，并用肥皂分子包裹任何碎片，当加入更多的水和摩擦时，它们很容易被冲走。为了你自己的健康以及其他所有人的健康，请定期洗手
at least 20 seconds. That is longer than you think. So pick a song to keep you on task. Long before I had you in my dreams, you came and captured my imagination. Those some things are never what they seem. I never have to worry, cause I know you are. Better than a Venus, to my little energy string, better than the promise of a good one night thing, better than a big book of Betty Page Pictures, even if it comes with a used subscription.
至少20秒。这比你想象的要长。所以挑选一首歌来让你专注于任务。早在我在梦中拥有你之前，你就来并俘获了我的想象力。虽然有些事情从来都不是它们看起来的那样。我从不必担心，因为我知道你是。比维纳斯更好，对我的小能量弦，比一个美好的单夜情的承诺更好，比一本厚厚的贝蒂·佩奇图片书更好，即使它附带了一个旧订阅。
Better than a ticket to a holy field ringside, better than a daughter for a Sultan, for a bride, better than a cherry on a whipped cream sundae, better than a weak fiddle, never have a Monday. Okay, that'll do. Okay, what's next? Let's walk down the stairs. And we are entering the hall. In his book at home, Bill Bryson wrote that no room has fallen further in history than
比一张通往神圣竞技场场边座位的票更好，比苏丹的一个女儿作新娘更好，比加了鲜奶油的圣代上的樱桃更好，比一把软弱的小提琴更好，永远不会有星期一。好吧，这就够了。好吧，接下来是什么？让我们走下楼梯。我们正在进入大厅。比尔·布莱森（Bill Bryson）在他的《家的简史》一书中写道，历史上没有哪个房间比
the hall. I always remember that line. I've been to Sterling Castle and Scotland a few times, and I love it there, especially the Great Hall, which has been painted a shocking and delightful, buttery yellow since its restoration in the 1990s. We did a story about it a few years ago. You should check it out. It seems impossible that a hall like the one in Sterling Castle and the hall in your house have a shared origin, but they do. The hall used to be everything.
大厅下坠得更厉害。我一直记得那句话。我去过苏格兰的斯特灵城堡好几次，我很喜欢那里，特别是大厅，自从20世纪90年代修复以来，它被涂成了令人震惊和喜悦的黄油黄色。几年前我们做过一个关于它的故事。你应该去看看。斯特灵城堡里的大厅和你家里的那个大厅有着共同的起源，这似乎是不可能的，但它们确实有。大厅曾经是一切。从
From the Middle Ages to about the 15th century, the hall was effectively the house, with a central hearth that people used to warm themselves and cook over. All activity took place there, awake and asleep. As soon as a second room was added to Holmes, the hall has been on a downhill slide. Now, it is this dumb thing, a non-room room whose primary function is to connect other rooms. So, you know, pour one out for the hall. If I turn right, I enter the living room. TV, I have a bunch of article furniture. I have a all-in-one laser printer scanner computer in here. Printers are curious technology because they are amazing and everyone hates them.
中世纪到15世纪左右，大厅实际上就是房子，里面有一个中央炉灶，人们用它来取暖和烹饪。所有的活动都在那里进行，无论是醒着还是睡着。一旦家里增加了第二个房间，大厅就一直在走下坡路。现在，它变成了这个蠢东西，一个非房间的房间，其主要功能是连接其他房间。所以，你知道的，为大厅倒一杯酒致意吧。如果我向右转，我进入客厅。电视，我有一堆Article的家具。我这里有一台一体式激光打印机扫描仪电脑。打印机是一项奇特的技
There are mentally a lot of things they hate. The criminal price of ink is a big one, and paper jams are another. According to an article in New Yorker called Why Paper Jams Persist, desktop printers will probably always have paper jams. The problem isn't really the printer. It's the paper. Paper is an organic substance that has different properties of thickness and texture depending on what kind of tree it came from and how it's processed. Commercial printers like the ones you see in the movies, we've had newspapers where, you know, someone gets to say, stop the presses.
术，因为它们很神奇，而每个人都恨它们。精神上有很多人讨厌它们。墨水的犯罪价格是一个大问题，卡纸是另一个。根据《纽约客》上一篇名为《为什么卡纸会一直存在》的文章，桌面打印机可能永远都会卡纸。问题其实不在打印机。是纸。纸是一种有机物质，根据它来自哪种树以及它是如何加工的，具有不同的厚度和纹理属性。商业打印机就像你在电影里看到的那种，我们有报纸，你知道的，有人可以说，停下印刷机。
Well, they have these long stretches where the paper goes in a straight line and, you know, gets ink put on it. But a desktop printer has to do everything in a tiny box. So the paper is pulled off the tray and makes a tight turn, gets rolled onto an ink drum where the image gets put on. Then it gets heated to almost 800 degrees Fahrenheit to fuse the ink to the page. And if you're printing double-sided paper, it stops and turns and gets turned again,
好吧，它们有很长的纸张直线运行并（你知道的）被印上墨水的路段。但是桌面打印机必须在一个微小的盒子里完成所有事情。因此，纸张从纸盘中被拉出，并做一个急转弯，被滚动到一个图像被印上去的墨水鼓上。然后它被加热到几乎华氏800度，以将墨水熔合到页面上。如果你正在打印双面纸，它会停下来并转动，再次被转动，
and gets rolled and heated, and it gets spit out. It's like truly a marvel that it works at all. The first commercially available copier, the Hulkin Xerox 914, which everyone loved and made Xerox billions of dollars, caught fire so often that it it shipped with a small fire extinguisher. So things could definitely be worse. Light bulbs. So we have a really good story that John Wellam wrote about the oldest continuously glowing light bulb that's been in a fire station and live more California for over 100 years. I don't really remember the details, so you should just find that episode and listen. It's good, but I do remember this one light bulb joke. Okay, how many psychiatrists does it take
然后被滚动和加热，然后被吐出来。这简直是个奇迹，它居然能运作。第一台市售复印机，哈尔金施乐914（Hulkin Xerox 914），每个人都喜欢它，并为施乐赚取了数十亿美元，它着火的频率如此之高，以至于它出厂时自带一个小型灭火器。所以事情绝对可能会更糟。灯泡。所以我们有一个非常好的故事，约翰·韦勒姆（John Wellam）写了关于自100多年以来一直点亮并位于加利福尼亚州利弗莫尔消防局的最古老的连续发光灯泡的故事。我不太记得细节了，所以你应该去找到那一集听一听。它很好，但我确实记得这个灯泡笑话。好吧，需要多少个精神病医生
to change a light bulb? One, but the light bulb has to want to change. All right. You can tell that one to the kids. I'm gonna walk into the kitchen. Oh, I've got one here. This is good. Okay, I'm going to open up this drawer here that you might recognize the sound of.
来换一个灯泡？一个，但灯泡必须想要改变。好的。你可以把那个讲给孩子们听。我要走进厨房。哦，我这里有一个。这个很好。好吧，我要打开这个你可能会认出声音的抽屉。
That is the silverware drawer. I have spoons, knives, and forks in here. Of these three common pieces of color, The fork is by far the most recent addition to the tableware family by probably like thousands of years. Straight to prong forks were used in cooking, for carving, and getting things off of a fire, but for a long time, they weren't on the different table itself. People use spoons, knives, and just, you know,
那是银器抽屉。我这里有勺子、刀子和叉子。在这三种常见的餐具中，叉子可以说是餐具家族中最新加入的成员，大概晚了数千年。直尖叉用于烹饪、雕刻以及将食物从火上取下来，但在很长一段时间里，它们并不在餐桌本身上。人们使用勺子、刀子，以及（你知道的）
their fingers instead. Forks were introduced a few times, you know, by fancy people, andks were introduced a few times, you know, by fancy people, and they were often ridiculed for it, but they only really took off when they evolved to have a little bit of curve in them and the extra time, so they could be more versatile for scooping and spearing small things on a plate. The curious thing about the evolution of the fork is how it changed the design of the knife. For millennia, table knives always had pointed ends for spearing food, but with the fork there, that function of the knife was redundant, so it could be eliminated.
而是用他们的手指。叉子曾被引入过几次（你知道的，由有钱人引入），并且经常因此而遭到嘲笑，但它们真正流行起来是在它们进化出了一点弧度并增加了叉齿之后，这样它们在舀取和刺穿盘子里的小东西时就能更加多功能。关于叉子演变的一个奇怪之处在于它如何改变了刀的设计。几千年来，餐刀一直都有尖头用于刺穿食物，但有了叉子后，刀的这一功能就变得多余了，因此它可以被取消。
In 1669, King Louis XIV of France decreed all pointed dinner table knives illegal, you know, to stop people from stabbing each other, which I guess was a problem then. So all new knives were made to have rounded tips and all existing table knives were to be rounded off to reduce their potential for violence. This style of knives spread across the world, which is why knives in your drawer, unless they're a specialty knife, probably have blunt ends. Okay, so I'm gonna save some stuff for the kitchen for the next time we do this, if we need to do this.
1669年，法国国王路易十四颁布法令，宣布所有尖头的正餐餐刀为非法（你知道的），以此来阻止人们互相刺杀，我猜这在当时是个问题。因此，所有的新刀都被做成带有圆头的形状，所有现有的餐刀也都被磨圆，以减少它们造成暴力的可能性。这种风格的刀具传遍了世界各地，这就是为什么你抽屉里的刀（除非它们是特种刀）通常都有钝端。好吧，所以我要留一些厨房里的东西，留到我们下次这样做的时候（如果我们必须这样做的话）。
And we're gonna end up back in the living room at the record player we do this, if we need to do this. And we're going to end up back in the living room at the record player. After this. One of the things I love about vinyl records is that you can see how they work. A needle reads the vibrations in a groove. That vibration moves a magnet that interacts with a couple of electromagnetic coils. And the signal that's generated is amplified a couple of times, and it's sent to the speakers. If my bone stops playing music, there is no hope of me getting it to work, but if everything in the world fails, I have this fantasy that I can put together a crappy record player if I had to, and that gives me some measure of comfort.
我们最终会回到客厅的唱片机旁，如果我们必须这样做的话。我们将在之后回到客厅的唱片机旁。黑胶唱片我最喜欢的一点是，你能看出它们是如何运作的。唱针读取音轨中的振动。这种振动移动一个与几个电磁线圈相互作用的磁铁。生成的信号被放大几次，并发送到扬声器。如果我的骨头停止播放音乐，我对让它工作就不抱任何希望了，但如果世界上的一切都崩溃了，我有一种幻想，那就是如果必须的话，我可以拼凑出一个蹩脚的唱片机，这给我带来了一定程度的安慰。
So I want to play the song Exit Without Saving by the BAM Beauty Pill from their album Beauty Pill describes things as they are, which is where I got the name for this episode. Chad Clark is the lead singer and songwriter of Beauty Pill. Over a decade ago his heart got infected by a virus that nearly killed him. Every sickness he's had since then has been a risk to his life and often involved him being hospitalized for days or weeks at a time. He has been blunt and sane that the new coronavirus would kill him if he got it. So, you know, I know it's hard to go through this quarantine and act in the collective good when the action that we're all taking is staying inside and minimizing
所以我想要播放来自Beauty Pill乐队的专辑《Beauty Pill描述事物本来的样子》（Beauty Pill Describes Things as They Are）中的歌曲《不保存退出》（Exit Without Saving），这也是我为这一集取名的地方。查德·克拉克（Chad Clark）是Beauty Pill的主唱兼词曲作者。十多年前，他的心脏被一种几乎要了他命的病毒感染。自那以后他得过的每一次生病都对他的生命构成了威胁，并且经常导致他住院数天或数周。他直言不讳地表示，如果他感染了新的冠状病毒，它会杀死他。所以，你知道的，我知道经历这次隔离是很艰难的，并且在我们的集体行动是呆在家里和尽量减少
contact and not, you know, like gathering 10 people to lift a car off someone. But taking care in this way is how we can do the most good. So you can help me lift a car off my friend, Chad Clark, because I need him to stay in this world and keep making music. And what's amazing is, at the same time, we're lifting a car off your 70 year old mom and nurse working at 12 hour shift at the hospital. So, here we go. The A five-time master on frozen mid-snarl, It attends un-cube advice, says I don't know how I got in here, but if I get out, it ain't gonna happen twice. I'm not having twice The towel is just two kids in a coat That comes here at night We've established what you are
接触，而不是（你知道的）像聚集10万人把一辆车从某人身上抬起来那样时，去为了集体利益行事是很艰难的。但以这种方式进行照顾是我们能够做出的最大贡献。所以你可以帮我把一辆车从我的朋友查德·克拉克身上抬下来，因为我需要他留在这个世界上并继续创作音乐。而令人惊奇的是，与此同时，我们也在把一辆车从你70岁的妈妈和在医院工作12小时轮班的护士身上抬下来。所以，我们开始吧。冰冻在咆哮中的五次大师，它听从无指导的建议，说我不知道我是怎么来到这里的，但如果我能出去，它不会发生第二次。我不会发生第二次。毛巾只是两个穿着外套的孩子，他们晚上来到这里。我们已经确定了你是什么
Now we're just haggling over the price No worries, right? You recognize that this is no one's right You recognize that this is no one's right You recognize that this is no one's right You still want it, no one's right You recognize that this is no one's right You recognize that this is no ice rind, you recognize it, this is no ice rind, you recognize it, this is no ice rind, you still run
现在我们只是在讨价还价。不用担心，对吧？你认识到这不是任何人的权利。你认识到这不是任何人的权利。你认识到这不是任何人的权利。你仍然想要它，这不是任何人的权利。你认识到这不是任何人的权利。你认识到这不是冰冷的坚硬外壳，你认识它，这不是冰冷的坚硬外壳，你认识它，这不是冰冷的坚硬外壳，你仍然在奔跑
Conny and I try, in a bottomless war, a hybrid of screaming yawn Whatever always happens here will always happen after you're gone. The care and fear of all of us causes can really save you of your precious, tall as right. You recognize this is no one's right. You recognize it, this is no one's right. You recognize it, this is no one's right. You still want it, no one's right.
康妮和我尝试，在一场无底的战争中，尖叫哈欠的混合体。无论这里总是发生什么，在你离开后也总是会发生。我们所有人的关怀和恐惧所造成的，真的可以拯救你那珍贵的、像高塔一样的权利。你认识到这不是任何人的权利。你认识到它，这不是任何人的权利。你认识到它，这不是任何人的权利。你仍然想要它，这不是任何人的权利。
You recognize this is no one is right You recognize that this is no one is right You recognize that this is no one is right You recognize that this is no one is right You still want it I'm not used to it But you still won't let me lie to myself I'm frozen with soul in a tent I'm keeping my voice I'm still not used to it, I don't know how I got it here But if I get it out, it ain't gonna happen to me Exit without saving.
你认识到这不是任何人的权利。你认识到这不是任何人的权利。你认识到这不是任何人的权利。你认识到这不是任何人的权利。你仍然想要它。我不习惯这样。但你仍然不让我对自己撒谎。我在帐篷里带着灵魂冻结，我保持着我的声音，我仍然不习惯这样，我不知道我是怎么来到这里的。但如果我把它弄出来，它不会发生在我身上。不保存退出。
From Beauty Pill describes things as they are. It's available on band camps. You can buy it right now without leaving your house. I think it's a masterpiece, but don't just take my word for it. Time magazine named it one of the best albums of the decade in amongst Beyonce and Kendrick Lamar, which is pretty amazing. But I also recommend that you use this time to support any artist that you enjoy, with your attention, and you know, if you can do it, your financial support.
来自Beauty Pill的《Beauty Pill描述事物本来的样子》。它可以在Bandcamp上买到。你不用离开家就可以马上买到它。我认为这是一部杰作，但不要只听我一面之词。时代周刊将其评为十年来最佳专辑之一，与碧昂丝和肯德里克·拉马尔并列，这相当令人惊叹。但我还建议你利用这段时间，用你的关注，以及（你知道的）如果你能做到的话，用你的资金支持来支持任何你喜欢的艺术家。
It might be rough for a while, for many of them. 99% of visible was produced this week by me, Roman Mars. We collectively are Avery Troubleman, Katie Mingle, Kurt Colestead, Delaney Hall, Sharif Youssef, and at Fitzgerald, Sean Rial, Joe Rosenberg, Vivian Leigh, Chris Baroube, and Sophia Klotzkar. Special thanks to our supporters, Tofer McCulloch, Steve Midgeley. That guy on a motorcycle. Houston Fortney. Stan, it's so loud.
对他们中的许多人来说，可能会有一段艰难的时期。本周的99% Invisible由我（罗曼·马斯）制作。我们集体包括阿弗里·特鲁布曼（Avery Troubleman）、凯蒂·明格（Katie Mingle）、库尔特·科尔斯特德（Kurt Colestead）、德莱尼·霍尔（Delaney Hall）、谢里夫·优素福（Sharif Youssef）、安·菲茨杰拉德（An Fitzgerald）、肖恩·里亚尔（Sean Rial）、乔·罗森伯格（Joe Rosenberg）、维维安·李（Vivian Leigh）、克里斯·巴鲁贝（Chris Baroube）和索菲亚·克洛茨卡尔（Sophia Klotzkar）。特别感谢我们的支持者托费尔·麦卡洛克（Tofer McCulloch）、史蒂夫·米奇利（Steve Midgeley）。那个骑摩托车的家伙。休斯顿·福特尼（Houston Fortney）。斯坦，声音太大了。
Sarah Carrier in DJ Shanty. We are a proud member of Radio Topia from PRX, a fiercely independent collective of the most innovative shows and all of podcasting. Find them all at radiotopia.fm. You can find this show and join discussions about the show on Facebook, you can be tweet at me at Roman Mars in the show at 99PIorg, who on Instagram and read it too. If you're looking for more stuff to listen to, we have hundreds and hundreds of stories at 9i9pi.org. As one of my favorite broadcasters, Mark Kermode says, everything will be alright in the end. And if it's not alright, it's not the end. There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
萨拉·卡里尔（Sarah Carrier）和DJ香蒂（DJ Shanty）。我们是PRX旗下Radiotopia的自豪成员，这是一个由播客中最具创新性的节目组成的激烈独立的集体。请在 radiotopia.fm 上找到它们。你可以在Facebook上找到这个节目并加入关于该节目的讨论，你可以在Twitter上@我（Roman Mars）并在节目@99PIorg上发推，也可以在Instagram和Reddit上找到。如果你正在寻找更多可以收听的内容，我们在99pi.org上有成百上千的故事。正如我最喜欢的广播员马克·克默德（Mark Kermode）所说，事情到最后都会好的。如果不好，那就不是终结。本集还没有评论。点击文稿中的任意句子来留下评论。